on nous dit que l'univers est en
expansion ok mais en expansion dans quoi
cette question là revient régulièrement
chaque fois que je parle d'expansion de
l'univers ou du big bang en général on
me demande aussi où est le centre de
l'univers ou a eu lieu le Big Bang dans
quoi l'espace-temps est-il courbé est-ce
que notre corps aussi est en expansion
pour répondre à toutes ces questions que
vous me posez souvent j'ai décidé de
faire une sorte de petite FAQ de
l'expansion de l'Univers et dans cette
vidéo je vais donc essayer de clarifier
tous ces points
[Musique]
commençons par les observations
astronomiques si on parle d'expansion de
l'univers c'est parce qu'on peut
l'observer et la mesurer si on regarde
un grand nombre de galaxies autour de
nous on se rend compte que quasiment
toutes les galaxies s'éloignent de la
nôtre et à première vue ça paraît assez
improbable comme situation si on vivait
dans un simple univers fixe rempli de
galaxies qui bouge on s'attendrait à en
avoir certaines qui s'éloignent mais
d'autres qui se rapprochent or on
observe que presque toutes les galaxies
s'éloignent de nous à plus ou moins
grande vitesse une façon de l'expliquer
ce serait de dire que notre galaxie a un
truc très particulier pour que toutes
les autres galaxies s'en éloignent comme
si on était une sorte de point central
de l'univers que toutes les galaxies
fuiraient aux apparaît assez peu
convaincant comme idée hein il y a des
milliards de galaxies observables
pourquoi la nôtre en particulier serait
spécial
d'autant plus qu'il y a un autre élément
troublant la vitesse à laquelle les
autres galaxies semblent s’éloigner de
nous si on trace un graphique qui donne
la vitesse d'éloignement de différentes
galaxies observables en fonction de leur
distance à nous voici ce qu'on obtient
ici la distance est en abscisse on
exprime ça en millions d'années-lumière
et on ordonné c'est la vitesse
d'éloignement de chaque galaxie en
kilomètres par seconde et vous voyez que
les galaxies les plus lointaines
s'éloignent le plus vite mais surtout
que la vitesse d'éloignement semble
proportionnel à la distance cette
relation de proportionnalité c'est ce
qu'on appelle la loi de Hubble Lemaître
on aurait beaucoup de mal à justifier
une observation de ce genre dans un
univers fixe rempli de galaxies qui
bouge il faudrait vraiment que tout soit
parfaitement réglé pour que ça se
produise et que notre position dans
l'univers soit vraiment très très
spéciale alors qu'au contraire cette
observation colle parfaitement avec
l'idée d'un univers en train de se
dilater
si c'est l'univers qui globalement se
dilate et bien ce serait logique que
toutes les galaxies s'éloignent les unes
des autres la nôtre n'aurait dans ce cas
rien de particulier et en plus de ça un
phénomène de dilatation globale
donnerait précisément une relation de
proportionnalité comme celle qu'on a vu
deux galaxies auraient l'air de
s'éloigner d'autant plus vite qu'elles
sont distantes cette idée de dilatation
globale de l'univers peut sembler
étrange mais en plus de coller
parfaitement aux observations elle
découle aussi des modèles cosmologiques
de l’évolution de l'univers qui nous
viennent de la théorie de la relativité
générale si on applique la théorie de la
relativité générale à l'univers dans son
ensemble on trouve qu'il est tout à fait
plausible qu'il puisse être en train de
se dilater on a donc d'un côté une
observation qui semble dire qu'il se
dilate et de l'autre une théorie qui
prédit que c'est normal qu'il se dilate
c'est que ça doit être vrai même si on a
du mal à l'appréhender parce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que l'Univers
dans son ensemble se dilate
alors une illustration qu'on donne
souvent pour essayer d'en faire une
image c'est celle d'un ballon de
baudruche supposé que notre univers
n'est que deux dimensions pour
simplifier et imaginons que l'univers
est la forme de la surface d'un ballon
de baudruche je représente les galaxies
comme des points dessinés dessus et si
je gonfle le ballon vous voyez que tous
les points s'éloignent les uns des
autres et l'éloignement est d'autant
plus rapide que les points sont distants
comme ce qu'on observant l'univers alors
cette image du ballon de baudruche est
sympa mais elle est loin d'être parfaite
bon déjà elle ne marche que pour un
monde en deux dimensions nous on vit en
trois dimensions d'espace alors parfois
on donne une autre image imaginez un
cake aux raisins en train de gonfler au
four le cake gonfle c'est comme l'espace
qui se dilate et tous les raisins se
retrouvent à s'éloigner les uns des
autres emportés par se gonflement ça
nous fait comme une expansion de
l'univers mais en trois dimensions alors
nouveau c'est une image et comme pour le
ballon de baudruche l'illustration assez
limite dans les deux cas le ballon et le
cake s'étendent certes mais dans un
espace 3D préexistant le ballon gonfle
dans l'espace 3D et le cake s'étend dans
les parties vides du four qu'il contient
si on prend trop cette image au sérieux
on pourrait croire que l'univers est
lui-même en expansion dans un espace
plus grand que lui qui le contiendrait
alors que non ce n'est pas ça qui se
produit il n'y a priori pas d'espace
plus grand ce que la cosmologie nous
décrit c'est un univers en expansion qui
s'étend qui se dilate mais qui ne se
dilate dans rien alors je sais c'est
assez compliqué à imaginer et pour
comprendre ça on va faire un petit
détour par une notion importante qui est
la notion de courbure je l'ai mentionné
la cosmologie utilise les équations de
la relativité générale cette théorie qui
nous décrit la courbure de
l'espace-temps et les équations
auxquelles elle obéit en particulier la
relativité générale nous dit que la
matière et l'énergie courbe
l'espace-temps
et l'expansion de l'Univers peut
d'ailleurs être vu comme une forme de
courbure temporelle alors quand on parle
d'un truc courbé dans le langage courant
on visualise souvent ça je prends une
feuille de papier et je peux la déformer
pour lui donner une certaine courbure
sauf que là on se retrouve avec le même
problème que tout à l'heure ma feuille
est un objet à deux dimensions mais pour
la courbée j'ai besoin d'une troisième
dimension à la troisième dimension
d'espace
on se représentant la courbure avec une
feuille on a l'impression que pour
courber quelque chose il faut disposer
obligatoirement d'une dimension
supplémentaire dans laquelle on va
courber mais en fait mathématiquement ça
n'est pas nécessaire et c'est même
restrictif quand on fait ça qu'on courbe
un objet au sein d'un espace qui a une
dimension supplémentaire on appelle ça
la courbure extrinsèque et ça n'est
qu'un cas particulier de courbure car en
mathématiques on peut aussi parler de
courbure intrinsèque la courbure
intrinsèque c'est une façon plus
générale de déformer les objets et pour
laquelle on a pas besoin de faire appel
à une dimension supplémentaire on peut
décrire la courbure d'un objet sans
avoir besoin de le plonger dans un
espace plus grand pour le déformer je
vais essayer de vous l'illustrer avec
une autre image simple
tout à l'heure j'ai pris une feuille de
papier et je lui appliquer une certaine
courbure j'aurais pu faire ça avec une
photo par exemple maintenant regardez
cette image que j'ai chargé dans un
logiciel de retouche
avec les outils du logiciel je vais
appliquer des déformations des
distorsions à l'image par exemple je
peux placer des points comme ça et créer
une sorte de grille et ensuite déplacer
ces points pour déformer mon image
je peux faire des trucs un peu tordus
comme ça et là ce que je suis en train
de faire c'est en quelque sorte de
courbé mon image initiale et pourtant
vous voyez bien que j'ai pas de
dimension supplémentaire ici et même il
est probable que les déformations que je
réalise ne serait pas faisable
simplement en imprimant ma photo et en
essayant de la courber dans l'espace à
trois dimensions
ce que je suis en train de faire là
c'est de donner une courbure intrinsèque
à mon image je la courbe mais je ne la
courbe dans rien alors ça paraît bizarre
et si le mot courbure est trop connoté
pour vous bah dites plutôt ou des
formations distorsion pour parler de
courbure on a pas besoin de dimension
supplémentaire et bien c'est ce genre de
courbure intrinsèque dont on parle en
relativité générale une façon de le
comprendre c'est de se dire que la
courbure intrinsèque est une déformation
qui modifie la manière de calculer les
distances imaginez une grille sur
laquelle je vais placer deux points et
supposer que je veuille calculer la
distance entre ces deux points si je me
réfère à ma grille vous voyez que mes
deux points sont séparés de 4 unités
selon la coordonnée horizontale de la
grille et de trois unités selon la
coordonnée verticale
pour calculer la distance entre les deux
points c'est facile j'ai juste à
appliquer le théorème de Pythagore dans
ce triangle rectangle la distance que je
cherche est l'hypoténuse du triangle et
je trouve que dans ce cas la distance
entre les deux points est de 5
bien imaginez maintenant que je déforme
ma grille comme tout à l'heure avec mon
logiciel de retouche regardez les
coordonnées sur la grille des deux
points sont toujours les mêmes il faut
que j'avance de 4 intervalles de grille
le long de cette ligne puis 3 le long de
celle-ci
et pourtant pour avoir la distance
physique entre les deux points et bien
appliquer simplement le théorème de
Pythagore ne marche pas ici mes deux
points sont à une distance plus grande
que tout à l'heure
la déformation de l'espace-temps a
courbure et bien on peut la voir comme
une conséquence d'une modification du
théorème de Pythagore dans un espace
intrinsèquement courbé le théorème de
Pythagore ne marche plus en tout cas il
faut le modifier alors en pratique ça se
fait en ajoutant des coefficients devant
le a² et le b² c'est coefficients
dépendent de la position et sont liés à
la courbure et la relativité générale
nous permet de calculer ses coefficients
en fonction de la matière et de
l'énergie présente alors pour ceux qui
connaissent le terme ces coefficients
c'est ce qu'on appelle la métrique de
l'espace-temps bref en résumé pour
courber l'univers on a pas besoin de le
courber dans quelque chose de plus grand
il est intrinsèquement courbé et cette
courbure intrinsèque se manifeste par
des déformations dans la façon de
calculer les distances entre les objets
et l'univers en expansion est en quelque
sorte un univers dans lequel toutes les
distances se dilatent car les
coefficients du théorème de Pythagore
augmentent mais sans que l'univers soit
en expansion quelque chose alors une
fois qu'on a bien sa en tête on peut
répondre à quelques autres questions
fréquentes qui portent sur le Big Bang
intuitivement quand on entend parler
pour la première fois de Big Bang on
s'imagine une sorte d'explosion très
localisée qui crée une bulle de matière
qui va gonfler sauf que si on se réfère
à cette image et ben ça pose plein de
questions ou a eu lieu le Big Bang où
est le centre de l'univers où ça s'est
peut-être produit quels sont les
galaxies qui sont le plus loin du centre
or vous voyez qu'avec l'image d'un
univers en dilatation intrinsèque et
bien ces questions n'ont plus de sens
l'univers n'a pas de centre il ne
s'étend dans rien ce sont juste les
distances qui changent intrinsèquement
et donc le Big Bang a eu lieu partout à
la fois pas dans un point particulier de
l'univers on a d'ailleurs souvent cette
question quand on parle de rayonnement
fossile il s'agit d'un rayonnement
électromagnétique qui aurait été émis
lors de la formation des premiers atomes
d'hydrogène environ 380 000 ans après le
Big Bang on peut encore observer les
reliques de ce rayonnement aujourd'hui
et il s'agit d'une des confirmations les
plus spectaculaires du modèle du Big
Bang ce rayonnement est observable tout
le temps partout et il nous arrive de
toutes les directions à la fois j'en ai
pas mal parlé dans des vidéos
précédentes or au moment de l'émission
de ce rayonnement les distances dans
l'univers étaient environ 1000 fois plus
petite qu'aujourd'hui
si on s'en tient à l'image initiale
d'une explosion localisée on peut voir
ça comme les reliques d'un feu
d'artifice mais si c'était le cas et
bien on ne devrait pas le voir en
permanence le rayonnement aurait dû
faire une perturbation passagère comme
Londe sonore de l'explosion du feu
d'artifice quand on entend le bruit de
l'explosion on l'entend une fois à un
moment bien précis suivant notre
distance et une fois que l'on ne nous a
passé c'est terminé et donc si le Big
Bang s'était produit quelque part en
particulier ce serait la même chose avec
le rayonnement fossile on aurait dû le
voir passer une fois et puis c'est tout
sauf qu'on l'a dit la dilatation de
l'univers est intrinsèque et les
missions du rayonnement fossile a eu
lieu partout à la fois
une image plus correcte ce serait donc
plutôt quelque chose comme ça tous les
points de l'espace ont émis du
rayonnement dans toutes les directions
et le rayonnement ce sont des photons et
donc aujourd'hui on a en permanence des
photons de se rayonnement qui se balade
partout et dans tous les sens
bien voyons maintenant encore quelques
questions fréquemment posées quand on
parle de l'expansion de l'Univers
[Musique]
si on regarde le diagramme que je vous
ai montré au début qui représente la
vitesse d'expansion en fonction de la
distance on voit que les vitesses
peuvent être très élevées ça va jusqu'à
40000 km par seconde pour des galaxies
situées à environ 2 milliards
d'années-lumière et donc si on extrapole
pour des galaxies qui seraient séparées
de plus de 15 milliards d'années-lumière
cette vitesse d'éloignement serait plus
grande que la vitesse de la lumière
or des galaxies situées à cette distance
de nous il y en a c'est un peu bizarre
non on a tous appris que rien ne peut
aller plus vite que la lumière et bien
ça n'est pas tout à fait vrai quand on
dit que rien ne peut dépasser la vitesse
de la lumière il faut préciser ce qu'on
entend la vitesse d'éloignement dont on
parle ici n'est pas une vitesse au sens
usuel de la relativité en relativité
restreinte on parle de la vitesse d'un
objet matériel mesuré dans un
référentiel local or ici ce sont les
distances qui se dilatent le référentiel
lui-même si vous voulez et donc pour
faire simple la limite de vitesse ne
s'applique pas ici
pour le dire de façon plus imagée les
galaxies sont comme des points sur une
grille et la grille se dilate et la
limite de vitesse ne s'applique qu'au
mouvement par rapport à la grille mais
pas à la dilatation elle-même quand on
regarde le mouvement d'une galaxie par
rapport à nous il faut distinguer le
mouvement dû à l'expansion et le
mouvement qu'on appelle propre il y a
d'ailleurs une galaxie pour laquelle la
distinction est importante pour nous
c'est la galaxie d'Andromède vous me
faites souvent la remarque que quand je
dis que toutes les galaxies s'éloignent
les unes des autres et vous avez raison
ça n'est pas le cas de la galaxie
d'andromènes avec la Voie Lactée la
galaxie d'Andromède se dirige vers nous
et va entrer en collision avec notre
galaxie d'ici quelques milliards
d'années
l'explication c'est que la galaxie
d'Andromède est très proche de nous 2,5
millions d'années-lumière alors oui
c'est très proche à l'échelle des
galaxies c'est seulement 25 fois le
diamètre de la Voie Lactée dans le
diagramme que je vous ai montré au début
elle se trouve donc par ici donc c'est
une galaxie pour laquelle l'effet
d'éloignement dû à l'expansion est très
faible tellement faible que le mouvement
propre de la galaxie est bien supérieure
et l'effet de l'expansion est
négligeable entre la voie lactée et la
galaxie d'Andromède la force de gravité
vient largement surpasser l'effet de
l'expansion et donc elle fonce sur nous
ou nous on fonce sur elle c'est pareil
d'ailleurs le cas de cette galaxie très
proche de nous ça me permet d'évoquer
une autre question qu'on me pose souvent
si tout se dilate dans l'univers comment
on fait pour se rendre compte de
l'expansion de l'Univers je dire si un
objet se dilate mais que la règle que
j'utilise pour le mesurer ce dilate
aussi et bien on devrait se rendre
compte de rien
et la raison c'est que non cette règle
ne se dilate pas bon déjà l'effet
d'expansion à l'échelle des objets
terrestres ou même du système solaire
est très très faible mais surtout il
existe d'autres forces en jeu bien
supérieur à l'effet de la dilatation la
gravité entre les astres et les forces
électromagnétiques qui assurent les
liaisons au sein des objets
prenons une règle métallique pour faire
simple disons en aluminium les atomes
d'aluminium sont arrangés en cristal et
la distance entre les atomes dans la
maille cristalline dépend des propriétés
de l'atome d'aluminium c'est environ 0,4
nanomètres et cette valeur ne vient pas
de nulle part c'est une distance
d'équilibre des atomes dans le cristal
si vous essayez de compresser le cristal
pour rapprocher les atomes et bien ils
vont se repousser et au contraire si
vous tirez sur le cristal pour les
éloigner ils vont se rapprocher
ça marche comme un ressort on peut même
modéliser les énergies associées avec
certains calculs de mécaniques quantique
bien maintenant si par l'effet
d'expansion de l'univers vous éloignez
deux atomes et bien il se retrouve dans
une position où la force de liaison va
les pousser à se rapprocher et cette
force électromagnétique de liaison est
bien supérieure à ce que peut faire
l'expansion de l'Univers à cette échelle
donc si on prend une règle ou n'importe
quel objet dont la cohésion est assurée
par des liaisons chimiques sa taille ne
changera pas à cause de l'expansion
l'univers et donc l'univers est en
expansion mais pas nous donc je suis
désolé ça n'est pas grâce à l'expansion
de l'univers que vous allez enfin
pouvoir augmenter la taille de votre
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si vous
voulez continuer à en discuter petite
nouveauté j'ai créé un serveur discord
de communautaire pour sciences étonnante
je vous mets le lien en description
n'hésitez pas à venir faire un tour
abonnez-vous pour ne rien rater mettez
la cloche et puis aussi surveiller
régulièrement la chaîne parce que
YouTube ne vous notifie plus
systématiquement quand je sors quelque
chose et puis avec tout ça je vous dis à
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo à
bientôt
[Musique]